time 100's coveted list dropped today
and look who snagged themselves a cover
spot birthday boy prince harry and
meghan markle
megan's in all white on the cover
standing just in front of harry who
turns 37 today but is the cover pick
just too perfect that's the buzz online
folks calling out the couple for looking
cgi and photoshopped
over in london harry's brother william
shared this pic and some birthday love
also making the time 100 britney spears
yesterday the pop star deactivated her
instagram account sending fans into a
tizzy well a source tells e.t everyone
can chill it's just a well-deserved
break and nothing should be read into
this this morning octavia spencer said
she's apologized to britt and her fiance
sam askari after making a joke after
their engagement that she should make
him sign a prenup octavia said her
intention was to make them laugh not
cause pain sam replied no hard feelings
whatsoever your friend britney spears is
engaged yes oh my god i didn't hear that
yet
britney's pal paris hilton wrote a
tribute essay for the issue quote
despite the darkness that has surrounded
her life britney embodies joy and shares
the light of her beautiful heart forever
the superstar
and only e.t has this exclusive video of
kate winslet and billy eilish behind the
scenes of their time cover shoots the
special issue hits newsstands on friday
also honored with one of the seven time
covers olympic gold medalist simone
biles it's been a whirlwind 48 hours for
the 24 year old
monday night she wore a custom gown to
the met gala in new york today she
fought back tears in d.c testifying in
the fbi's investigation of former team
doctor larry nassar we have been failed
and we deserve answers
[Music]
you